there's a character I didn't I think
it's very cool that the LA Kings let you
do this oh yeah you do they let you be a
commentator for the LA Kings and you
decided to do it in character as a guy
named Babcock Oni Babcock here we have a
picture I think of Tony Babcock yeah I
was asked you know hey do you want to
come by you'll come by for like a game
right talk abut talk amongst the pundits
and I said can I do it as a character
had a mustache that's immediately funny
yep and a corduroy jacket again very
hilarious and just tried to like smash
up all my sort of secondhand absorbed
hockey knowledge into one person who
just sort of says like well look at that
he put the he surely put the mustard on
the hotdog with that shot like it
doesn't make much sense we're people
getting annoyed that you were this
character I think a character like that
works great when the team is doing well
if the team is struggling in that season
it's a bit like and now we got this guy
yeah so what kind of things you just
babbling out you were up there babbling
and I understand you use a little
off-color language at one point oh they
brought me
hey hats off to anyone working in like
sports because it's crazy like
everything is so quick and now they're
going up here and I was like totally a
little bit deer in headlights but yeah
they brought me up to the play-by-play
and they they're keep trying to feed me
they're like hey does improv ok look
like well throw some loaded stuff and so
like by the end of it my character was
he had gotten injured so much like every
year he gotten injured so injured so
much that's why he came a pundit and at
one point I said oh yeah I've had just
about every bone broken in my body I've
been injured from tip to tail
and seconds later they were like hey man
thanks alright we're done with the play
they got you out of there you're telling
me I can't say taint ya live
play-by-play commentary on a hockey game
shocker Todd what are you thinking we
have a I think we have a piece of tape
of you doing it do we not holy smokes
that's enough spicy mustard on that
hotdog to make you regret your choices
tomorrow morning a lot of razzle Lata
dazzle and everybody's invited to the
magic show
first Clifford the Big Red Dog then to
Foley and now Carter hot dog it's three
Nils the best part about it is there's
the NHL Awards in a couple weeks they're
bringing me back I'm gonna bring back
fateful from commercial to people to
athletes who have worked their entire
lives to get there to get there where
they are they're finally win their
accolades and they're getting this Dumbo
to be like I don't know back to you in
the studio
like why it's just wasting people's time
it's a hundred percent wasting people's
time and you'e clapped and you
encouraged it so there's now only gonna
be more of it
[Applause]